I have to say I have great affection for
Weekend At Bernies when's the last time
you've seen it and have you watched it
with any of the uh well I can
shamelessly tell you that I was in a
hotel about a month ago and I flipped on
the TV and I went into the bathroom as I
told you and I started hearing this
voice I'm like what is that and I went
back in it was me and Weekend at
Bernie's and I watched like the last it
was the boat scene of chasing Dan so I
watched like the last 20 minutes of the
movie and it's a smile oh dude I'm not
even smiling I was sitting there
reciting the lines back to the TV alone
in my hotel room and I can't remember
ever watching a movie mine like that uh
ever